welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast
this is are you garbage it's a show we
sit down with your favorite communities
we find out if they grew up classy
or if they're absolute trash i'm your
host holy coming at you
on a beautiful evening from an
undisclosed location
somewhere in the continental united
states we got the heat on us folks
we're still out there on the lamb my
co-host
i don't even know where he is all right
i don't even know they don't even tell
me
plausible deniability next thing you
know i'm in some warehouse in brooklyn
getting my fingernails pulled out he's
not that much of my friend i could tell
you that
i would cough you up in a second give it
up
for the boss man kippy kevin james ryan
never rob a bank with this guy jeez last
guy you wanted a foxhole with you it was
the
it was the bald guy with the big
forehead get him what you want to do is
you want to go two doors down there's
going to be a broad standing there ask
her she's
right up the steps yeah what's up
everybody
uh as always thanks for listening please
make sure you rate review subscribe on
itunes
full video available on yo youtube those
numbers are true to [ __ ] roof
also that dot com is cooking
with my gasoline dude we gotta put out a
[ __ ] help wanted sign we need we need
another line cook back there
that place is bustling dude that place
is on do patreon.com sign yourself up
get some [ __ ]
hot bonus episodes if you're not
familiar with what you should be
you get bonus episodes at ayg you get
episodes of hard feelings which the
people are
[ __ ] loving by them is that the
surprise hit of the season
it is i didn't see i thought that was
just gonna be me and you
you know me calling you fat you calling
me bald for an hour and people are
loving it so i was watching the golden
globe nominations waiting to hear about
hard feelings on there
so you so you can get patriot you can
get hard feelings and then also
each uh each month we're gonna do we do
a live stream with the top tier members
uh where we play ayg with you guys you
ask us questions we ask you questions
it's a good [ __ ] time guys
great time get involved with that you
know what i mean
that's what you're saying get in the
campaign vote foley kippy 2024 let's go
baby let's [ __ ] do it
and i don't like this how i feel like
i'm in one of the kids from malcolm in
the middle rooms
and where were you the [ __ ] united
arab emirates
whatever it's called where are you dubai
you're somewhere
real shifty i'm currently in the
norwegian consulate right now
i'm technically i'm technically in the
country of norway in midtown if you want
to know
you're planting bugs in the pakistani
[ __ ] embassy
i'm dressed i'm dressed like an
exterminator i'm just like spraying
mustache on your eyes this gets all
[ __ ] up
they're gonna get them they're gonna get
them you know what i was thinking about
today before we get and this is a family
episode obviously gang we're still not
quite
back yeah still hemmed up a bit so we're
coming at you from remote locations next
week
we should be [ __ ] revving to go also
little nope sorry a little bit more
business
unless snowden starts running his mouth
you know what i mean
he's in the other room want me to get
him
eddie hey dork lose the glasses and keep
your mouth shut will you
you're killing us zip it will you
call down to the front desk for some ice
will ya
my scotch is getting cold let's go i got
capri suns i got a meltdown
hey radio shack why don't you keep that
mouth shut
[ __ ] usa kid let's go
that's two a little bit more business
the card should be going out in the next
couple of days
obviously we got hemmed up everything's
at the studio we can't go in so
you know we will uh in the next couple
of days hopefully everything clears up
and we can get them out for you
people have been hitting me up i feel it
feels like a ponzi scheme but have they
already start hitting you
oh you're gonna make me nervous oh stop
it no just call people like yo you know
when they're going out this that um
yeah they should be going out very soon
very soon we're trying we're [ __ ]
hemmed up dude we're trying to operate
oh
there's a [ __ ] global pandemic going
on that message was from the queen's
county sheriff by the way
it came with a season a season desist
letter as well
you boys want to come in quietly or go
out in a shootout
i think that's from the simpsons when
they try to take ned flanders away
um i tell you what i was thinking about
before we get into the questions this is
the family
episode just the family it's just us you
look like you're on america's funniest
videos
it looks like someone's gonna run up and
kick in the nuts
i feel like a sugar glider should jump
on my face
this is what happens when me and the big
man don't spend time together we get a
little loopy
hang on a second hello the giggles yeah
i'm here
oh man i'm having a chuckle today
get the cardio huh this is all you need
a little ayg
in your life oh man oh that's good
that's what i'm saying i don't like i
don't like this disparage
whatever it's called this district your
lighting looks all good
yeah like so i'm at a hotel in
uh in brooklyn we're doing a little bit
of a staycation
uh my wife's been sitting in the [ __ ]
apartment for
you know she's gotten she just moved
here before
you know the pandemic so she's been
hemmed up in the apartment so
we got a good deal through her through
work for this a week a couple of days
we're doing bk
very nice getting it on the cuff almost
it's pretty cheap
i don't trust you two as far as i can
throw you okay meanwhile
i'm at what wait what the guy heard an m
i hope he didn't say what you think i'm
saying
you got company privileges on the
minibar no no
and dude cause i'll be over
um dude those these prices on the
[ __ ] mini bar there's like a 16 ounce
bot not even 60. yeah probably about a
12-ounce bottle of whiskey and it's 120
bucks
for the 16 ounce bottle of [ __ ]
whiskey i said yo
buddy i got a [ __ ] there's a there's
a bodega on the corner i'll get a six or
a paps
zip it let's go dude if you did some
[ __ ] like that one my old man's credit
card was done at the front desk
[ __ ] kong better be coming this
better be it
no way i don't even look at it my my
girl put leftovers in the
in the fridge and i'm worried they're
gonna [ __ ] i'm worried they're gonna
charge us for something you know what i
mean be like hey hotel leftovers
man [ __ ] we are on hard times we are
treading water here
jesus christ hippie's bringing leftovers
back to a hotel
no we ordered there's a the kitchen in
the hote you know in one of the
restaurants
they don't do rooms they're not doing
anything you got to go off and pick it
up and then you can bring it back down
and eat in the room
like a jerk off yeah like a real but
while i was up there
wait so we went up because everything's
25 you're allowed 25
you know t 25 capacity in new york now
but we we were like oh let's just go
look and it's it was just not our
this is our this is also one i want to
get to
when you're we're staying at a nice
hotel obviously on
you know you've made that clear on a
discounted rate
um yikes we are but they don't look you
the same but that's what you're asking
they know you're both they don't they
don't know i think i don't know how it
works
i don't know how it works but i think
we're getting it on the back end or
something i don't know what's going on
is the montego somewhere in the vicinity
now i drove it into the east river
i think i left off the bridge what am i
jerk off um
there's just i don't understand why rich
people are mean
everybody's so nice dude like there was
like
some sort of like a discrepancy with the
room when we got here what
we were going to get or what we thought
we were something like just like oh i
thought we were going to have
this something and like the way they
hand
is just so polite like if that would
have happened in like a [ __ ]
you know a red roof inn and [ __ ]
cleveland dude [ __ ] guns would have
been pulled like dude
but they're just like oh sure i'm so
sorry mr ryan do you mind you wanna go
get a complimentary drink it's all
[ __ ] bananas
listen dude this is just our policy i
don't know what to tell you it's a store
policy i can't do anything about it
sorry man
yeah yeah that's not what i'm saying
that [ __ ] don't like
for rich people that [ __ ] don't i mean
not even rich we're at a [ __ ] hotel
in brooklyn it's not like we're at like
the four seasons or something
but even just like when you're spending
a little bit they spend a little bit of
cash
everybody's nice and i'm so like they're
going to catch me they're going to know
something's up you know what i mean
it's the second they're not that's when
you get into trouble the second they're
not and you have some [ __ ] rich dude
freaking out and see rich people know
how to do it right
they're not going to cause a scene most
of the times down there at the [ __ ]
uh at the front desk what they're going
to do is they're going to reach out to
whatever
[ __ ] travel coordinator or wherever
the [ __ ] or whatever their right-hand
man is going to get yelled at
he's going to get yelled at which in
turn is going to fire off an email to
the concierge
which is going to end up getting [ __ ]
debbie at the front that's [ __ ] fired
yeah yeah it's no better scumbags
i mean i could get used to having a
little bit of cash but
unfortunately i don't but i could get
used to it you like bossing people
around jerk off yeah we all do
all right you like getting [ __ ] 20
burgers living up to the room
i wish what did they get you for a
burger over there
i just threw the receipt out well this
is also how trashy i am so we go up
um he kept your receipt for room service
no it can't no well if you get
no need to go any further no it's
takeout
it's takeout um so we go up to like the
restaurant and we were going to order
and we were like do you want to sit here
because it was completely empty
and it was like a nice view we're like
oh we could sit here and chill or we
could go back down to the room but they
were playing music or whatever
and uh my wife's like i'm gonna go back
down to the room like this isn't my vibe
i'm like oh i'll stay here and get the
burgers you know what i mean
but while i'm standing there waiting for
the burgers i
[ __ ] scold like [ __ ] four ipas
dude i was just
like this waitress was looking at me
like i was [ __ ]
oh my like dude it was a scene
people make sure them fries are well
done
dude with and they were like nine or ten
dollar beers too but they were so i
haven't had one in a handful of days
they were
nice going down that's the thing about
real booze bags man
[ __ ] put two or three away real quick
get [ __ ] straight
get my head right you know what i mean
[ __ ] clear the head a little bit get
back in reality
take the [ __ ] edge off you know you
know you know what i would go ahead you
got
something i'm just saying but no one
like i'm so trapped no one else is doing
that
no one else was up there [ __ ]
slamming [ __ ]
merman ipas or whatever i was doing now
maybe a prosecutor from the southern
district or something like that staying
there who's got a [ __ ] tough day
ahead of them
sure after a long day or something yeah
yeah yeah
no that's not a good sign
you know what i wanted to say to you was
uh you really have
uh a plethora of cheap foreman
to workmen sayings and i realized that
just so just from this week you know
we're gonna be treading water for a
little bit
yeah at friday's payday yeah
you always pay that you just made that
one up
i mean that's not that's not even insane
dude what could that even mean
i don't know work smarter than harder or
something like you're always hitting me
with
some of those sure sure sure got to get
done going to get done's a big one
yeah that's what that's what my whole
family was they were all you know the
project managers to journeyman the
[ __ ] you know at the whole
so i just got all the i grew up pretty
much on a job site so i just know all
the lingo you know what i mean
trying to keep my head above water huh
you know what i mean
i'm over here with a [ __ ] roll of
quarters in my mouth what are you doing
and i was thinking now that we got the
when we get back to today's now that we
have the new tv
we can we get cable at hoodies
so we can watch we can watch the fights
or something like that
have a couple oh you want to be schultz
is what you want yeah
now you're getting it i mean we could
it would be an additional expense of
probably like 50 bucks a month that's
patreon.com folks
yeah i'm not paying for [ __ ] you know
well here's the thing
what i was thinking about this today
okay and it got me thinking about
something i knew you would say that i
knew you would say
more or less that i would probably have
to pay for it if i wanted it you could
pay for it
i was curious about two things before we
get into the questions sure
what was uh what was your chore
situation as a kid
and did they ever make you pay for
anything because
i i don't know if i've ever told you
this and i thought it was i always
thought this was really really garbage
we might have talked about this a little
bit but not in depth
i had a buddy who from like the age of
12
until the age of 16 or 18 whenever he
left the house
he had to pay his cable bill
what that's bananas what the [ __ ] kind
of heathens are you hanging out with
i don't know but i remember i was like
15 when he told me and like it dude it
almost broke my heart i didn't want to
watch tv at his house anymore
was he one of those kind of kids that
got like divorced from his divorce from
his parents when he was like 14
like those kids or the parents sign him
off and he doesn't have to go to school
he's smoking out front you're like
what's this guy all about what do you
think he's hanging out with
he's he's a mechanic when he's like 13
you're like what the [ __ ] is jimmy doing
what do you think i'm hanging out with
drew barrymore no he was a regular
kid yo i was just telling my wife that
problem was doing blow it when she was
like 11.
oh she was up she was up to it she was
dude i remember when i was a little kid
i was in love with her
she's like i think like almost my exact
same age
um yeah no that's i never did that and
then the true
i never really had to pay for anything
like i had this like you you know you
would collect money from like birthdays
or
you know whatever you had a little bit
of scratch that's how you got your
you would keep the change when you went
to get the pizza whatever that was
always about four or five bucks
put that piggy back because you were
skimming i was
oh yeah i was cooking the books at an
early age
um yeah oh i mean we've talked about
that you always take the change
yeah come on listen we know each other
we're friends
just you and me here all right tony's
not around
of course i still take that what you're
not getting changed back
i know um so
i would buy stuff if like i won i
remember really one time i wanted like a
a camcorder i wanted like uh i wanted to
make movies and stuff and like film i'm
not like
you know whatever i just wanted to
record stuff i thought that was cool so
i bought a camcorder for like 400 bucks
when i was like 12 or something
shot a couple of home pornos no big deal
um
but like my parents were like yeah if
you want to buy that like you buy that
but like i wasn't like
i wasn't buying milk and [ __ ] i wasn't
like i wasn't contributing to the
[ __ ] household
i can't believe i didn't bring it up
until until now
i was watching because i was thinking
about getting cable here and it made me
think about
today's and all that stuff and i just
remember thinking back man like on the
couch one day in the middle of summer
and this is when like you know we were i
mean
we weren't poor but we weren't doing
fantastic but we didn't know we were
getting by you know what i mean [ __ ] was
great
sure but there was like a certain level
of
um things like you never thought about
or never
or never considered and you know luckily
[ __ ] the cable and the palette all
that stuff wasn't one of them
and i remember it was like a hot summer
afternoon we were sitting there on his
[ __ ] couch
and i just remember him like as i'm
flipping and we're like we were like
fighting over the remote or something
like that he's like i gotta pay for that
and i'm like
take my tell your mom i'll take my
cheez-its to go
ask for a ziploc bag because i am
hitting
the bricks okay i felt horrible for the
kid
yeah i never did that and does very well
now does very well
i'm sure he's but [ __ ] pain he was
paying utility bills in elementary
school why the [ __ ]
i mean that kid's got a good head on his
shoulders he should be retiring soon
this guy was doing accounts receivable i
know um i didn't know
i was terrible with that man god loved
my parents i never
i never if they tried to teach me i
never soaked any of that stuff
up about money how to manage money what
to do where'd it go
how to study no no no i got i got none
of that i was thought i was saying that
to my mom the other day i'm like if
somebody even like
kind of was like oh you don't spend
money you don't have i would have been
like oh really you don't do that you
know
like even that little bit um
and chores i had to like to trash it was
big i dreaded it like bringing the trash
up and down letting the dog out that
kind of [ __ ] you know
mowing the lawn had to mow the lawn all
the time
had the motor on hate it
mow the lawn or rake the leaves in the
fall uh you want to see two foley boys
with two big pusses on their faces
ah all right let's get into some
questions but before we do let's take a
quick second kip
let's talk about our old friends in the
old big show what's that
over there on the stereo app that we do
every thursday night at nine o'clock
answering your guys questions it's a
good time
yeah guys check it out if you're not
familiar uh stereo dot com slash kevin
ryan or slash h foley
for uh you know for the we've been doing
it for what a
couple of weeks now a handful of weeks
going to want some more
every thursday night you guys get to ask
us questions we answer them live on the
air it's a good time it's a good way for
you to get involved with us and the show
you know what i mean just additional
content for you check it out
stereo dot com slash kevin ryan slash h
foley we get to wet our beaks
oh yeah it's a good time and then also
from our other sponsor to good folks
over there
at cushy dreams baby fully
creeping up on my favorite sponsor
creeping up on my favorite sponsor
they they really know what they're doing
guys 2020 was a rough year for everybody
and 2021 is starting out just
as [ __ ] crazy you know what i mean so
our good friends at cushy dreams can
help
cushy dreams specializes in high quality
smokable cbd
and cbd has been shown to help with
anxiety depression pain relief
inflammation
from a to zeke the seed cbd helps
um foley is i mean they sent us samples
and i mean
it's very rare that like foley takes the
lead he stole
all of the cushy dreams i gotta i gotta
be honest with you he [ __ ] hijacked
the studio
i stole all the cushy dreams i stole the
two container uh containers that have
some flour in it and then i took three
pre-rolls and i i remember i
left the studio we had her we had a
rough day that day i [ __ ] got in the
car i drove home and as i was walking
towards my house
i lit up the uh the cushy dreams dreams
[ __ ] half of that set me completely
straight went upstairs relaxed had a
great night
and i've been [ __ ] hitting it every
once in a while man i i love it the
dreams put me to sleep i take a hit out
of the hustle in the morning
get going it makes me feel good dude you
don't feel high it's fantastic
get on that cushy dreams gang yeah and
smoking it is the fastest and most
effective way to get cbd into your
system the flower looks smells taste
like high quality
marijuana every run is limited small
batch this is you know independent [ __ ]
we're talking about here it goes through
all the tests
compliance purity all the info is on the
website
get some high quality cbd and fight back
against anxiety and the crazy world
uh go to cushydreams.com that's
k-u-s-h-y
at check checkout use promo code garbage
baby it's always garbage g-a-r-b-a-g-e
for 20
off your next order free shipping on
orders over 20 bucks smoke your cbd
with promo code garbage for 20 off
today now back to the show
baby and look at that we're already here
doing live
reads talk about a couple of guys
working with no net right now you think
it's all moonlight and canoes
we ain't there yet i know first of all
fighting through it
you know people like i've loved the
[ __ ] fans so some people are like
the best they're they're honestly
[ __ ] awesome
but some of the comments were like
foley's only coming out of my left ear
i'm like
yeah buddy you're looking i'm like we
[ __ ] this thing's put together with duct
tape kippy did all the engineering on it
buddy
you're lucky i didn't drop off a cd at
your house to listen to this [ __ ]
thing
be burning copies remember that when cds
would just show up at your house like cd
right different
cd-roms and stuff like that yeah he used
to have like four million hours of
[ __ ] aol online or whatever
they just sent them out oh really that's
what that was i would never put
something like that on my computer
something that came in the mail
yeah too busy looking at your [ __ ]
dirty movies like there's not enough
viruses in those things back in the
early 2000s i was a blu-ray kid i don't
know what to tell you
um all right let's get into some [ __ ]
questions here let's have a good time
yeah we love it give them the spiel
kippy i'll do the spiel while you're
doing that
as you know when you sign up for
patreon.com
you get your question asked on the air
oh yeah
yeah guys uh you know as we we get so
many requests um
you know people are sending in i like
how you do it you know
uh well just people uh send in so many
i don't want to feel it's just i don't
want to sound like a dick but this is
the best way to do it so when you sign
up for patreon we'll read your you know
we'll read your questions and
we there we have a bit of a backlog
we're going to get to everybody we
appreciate all the [ __ ] support
i can't help that the patreon's cooking
baby to fish are jumping on a boat you
know what i mean
i can't get all backlogged we're just
getting to them yeah the beard's coming
in real nice
yeah one of the ladies said i should
grow a beard too what do you think him
not my ladies something we grow one here
but a forehead nah get a little merkin
all right you're a funny guy we got a
funny guy this guy's a real funny guy
um all right this one's just funny uh
this is from jono
did you debate uh signing off for
patreon after the first of the month to
avoid two charges
also did you use a montana zip code to
avoid taxes
johnny my [ __ ] man
that is a [ __ ] i mean this guy i
thought i was playing chess
not checking what's up in montana what's
up in montana you don't gotta pay
i guess it's like delaware probably i
guess they don't have sales tax or
something i tell you my eyes have been
on three states ever since you told me
that texas
florida and now montana i like what i'm
hearing
oh yeah that's the income tax yeah yeah
yeah tax bracket foley huh
down there in miami mixing it up with
gronk and tommy b
well i mean you technically could you
could set it up you know you'd just be a
resident and your income would come from
there or something i don't know how it
works what do i look like
um this is from jeff what a real shifty
guy
yeah guy who knows how to fudge some
numbers like i'm currently in a hotel
room under a german name right now
what do i know
12 with 12 passports in
different countries denominate money
what the [ __ ] i know i don't know what
just happened there all right this is uh
i don't think we've done this this one's
from garrett wait hold on
to answer that question that's something
that we've
we we are aware of and we've discussed
that
you know what i mean we don't want to
bang people out for two things sure but
people no so
but also if you sign up you get to l so
if you sign up you get to listen to all
of the past episodes you know what i
mean so if you sign up for the five
dollar level you get [ __ ]
five months worth of [ __ ] already for
that five bucks you know so it's like
that's that's the way people view it
that's the way that's viewed on patreon
but yes wait till the first and sign up
at the first whatever you need
absolutely yeah we're all about it but
we're all about the savings here i do
the same kind of [ __ ]
i know yeah yeah you do you i got i i
don't hate it
i only keep cable i only keep my
internet going for 23 days out of the
month
shut it down for a week yeah take a take
they take the day off you know what i
mean
um this is from garrett i don't think we
did it did you ever have a lucky
rabbit's foot
dude we've talked about this have we
i've
yeah i've i've asked this as a question
and let me tell you something
if the answer is yes get the [ __ ] out of
here i
felt one of those things dude i remember
where they i still don't know were they
real rabbits feet
i'm sure some of them were but either
way
how is that good who is it who are you
hanging out with davey crockett what the
[ __ ] going on here
who's walking around with animal parts i
knew a couple of guys that had them like
on their keychains and stuff like that
that that shit's really we're really
running with the cool crowd huh
pillars of industry everybody's got
[ __ ] animal pelts on their
you [ __ ] loser dressed up like you're
[ __ ]
[ __ ] dressed up like braveheart
walking to lunch
[ __ ] rabbits feet snake skins frog
legs
it's like [ __ ] pet cemetery over here
with these guys
yeah they're moving i never i remember
somebody i remember my buddy neal showed
me one he was like
my lucky rabbit's foot i was like check
please buddy
[ __ ] i think i gotta get home
later lucky rabbit's foot didn't your
grandma just die
how lucky then your brother just get hit
by a bus
did you just lunch it in the [ __ ]
kickball game what do you
dude looking back on that how the [ __ ]
that i would love to know the origin of
that how that brings you luck to have a
cute little bunny's
foot i could see if it was okay a bear
claw
or something like that you know what are
you in the revenant shut up
you got to earn it or like a hawk's beak
or something like that you know what was
big when i was a kid
was real big a shark's tooth
dude how corny was a [ __ ] sharks ah
man right up there with a puka necklace
oh
yeah dude i used to rock a shark's tooth
like you made it all the way to the
ocean city boardwalk look at you
you're a really tough guy no we went to
the camden aquarium
we didn't even make we didn't even make
it to the coast
ah what a scumbag he made some intern go
in there and get it hey get in there
will you
i want one from the back too a little
fat gippy sitting there eating a dinner
roll
let me get a molar will you dad tell
this bum i want a molar will you
and my kid says he wants a molar all
right sir
dude sharks teeth take a hike
yeah it was time beat it it was tough um
you know what i've been wanting to bring
up i just ha i didn't know when to bring
it up and i was
relatively afraid to bring it up in
front of a guest you know what i mean i
wasn't sure how bieber
would be you know taken but i remember
at one point when i was like a teenager
i don't know 10 or something i
found where you know i don't know if she
was keeping above
my teeth from when i was a kid my baby
teeth like when i would lose them
and my babysitter was doing it who's
doing it oh my mom
the beast that i was just like a
neighbor
yeah that's my neighbor ducky collecting
my teeth
mr williamson don't forget to bring
those teeth over here
that and my boogers um
hey buggers in your underwear bring that
over uh she was saving them that's
i think she would i don't know i don't
know i found
a handful of them in like a something
when i was older and i'm like what are
these she's like uh they were from when
you were younger i was like oh my god
yeah bitched on my teeth yeah you
[ __ ] loser
it was a trick question i didn't think
it was a set of keys honey
what the [ __ ] are you doing with him
[ __ ] buffalo bills my mom what the
[ __ ]
yeah it was a little sketchy i was i was
that's like one of those things where
i'm like all right
moving on dude i don't i remember my
brother brought one home
from uh he had
he had shark's teeth which was weird um
now he brought a molar home that he had
pulled and it was like perfect
like they had gotten the root and
everything out of it i remember that
lasted like a night in the house and my
mom was like get that [ __ ] thing out
of here
go bury that in the yard or something we
don't want that in here yeah that's
bullies don't like that's superstition
[ __ ] we don't like that
we don't want teeth or bones or anything
like that
[ __ ] pet cemetery we used to yeah you
got cremated you're out on the deck
you're not coming inside i'll tell you
that
it's not crossing the entrance not
crossing the portal to the to the
domicile
yeah you get doused in garlic water and
leave it you're hanging out you're
hanging out at the pool at club foley
you get you get to you get to cool off
in the summer but you ain't coming in a
house
no no they don't go for that they don't
know
that's [ __ ] funny um this one's just
this one's insane this is from pinkrazio
finally got the sand out of my [ __ ] and
booked a one-way flight to wuhan ramirez
uh shout out to the history irenas um
shout out to the hitchhikinis
uh have you this is bananas have you
ever washed your d
washed your dishes in the shower
what i guess if they were too much for
some i don't [ __ ] know but no the
answer is no and i think if you're doing
that that's
a you should go to jail or something
that's like college dorm [ __ ] maybe
or if you live in a motel when you're
staying weekly at the motel maybe you
[ __ ]
you wash out a pot of ramen in the
shower with you
no kitchenette yeah that's nuts i
i uh that's that's kooky i don't i guess
people do it though i mean if he's
asking
that's the thing some of these questions
are [ __ ] bonkers
but then people like comment they're
like oh i do that and i'm like oh my god
we got some
real dirt balls listening to the show i
like it i love it i know
i know that's that's crazy i feel like
i'm waiting for
somebody to come in and assassinate you
from those curtains right now i feel
like
i'm kind of it's kind of born supremacy
a little bit right just waiting for a
silencer
i'm waiting for a shadowy figure to come
in [ __ ]
um all right this is okay let's go
uh this is from jeff charmin on the old
patreon air is it garbage to eat peanut
butter out of the jar with a spoon
it is but it's also one of my favorite
things
man i'm telling you i've i remember the
first time my buddy liam
showed me that you could i was we did it
at his house which is gross you do it at
someone else's house it's
disgusting oh yeah i mean i would say
even it's disgusting if you do it at
your family's house i have my own peanut
butter that nobody touched well i'm
saying if you do it in europe if
it's you and your girl you do it a year
it's whatever you know what i mean of
course yeah yeah of course
but even as a kid if you have multiple
family members mixed in there
because i don't know about you but the
peanut butter wasn't kept we we didn't
know about peanut butter storage the way
we know about
now i'll be going with it it was in the
fridge
usually what yeah we were we didn't know
we didn't know then cannot not put it in
the fridge it was in the fridge
let me tell you how many loaves of bread
i tore the [ __ ] up
dude a piece of white bread does not
stand a chance against some [ __ ] cold
pb
what are you doing like the polish
fighting off the blitzkrieg you know
what i mean
it worked out [ __ ] scorched earth
daddy oh no
bad news and there would always be like
a piece of butter or jelly or crumbs or
something dude
crumbs and a peanut butter oh dude i can
tell a lot about your upbringing if i go
to your house and you got crumbs in your
peanut butter you're trash
um first of all you're putting peanut
butter on toast which is [ __ ] suspect
oh dude big pb dude [ __ ] peanut
butter on
peanut butter on [ __ ] white toast
with a huge glass of milk
oh my god that'll [ __ ]
dude i only get i only got that on my
birthdays
good night
on election day you get one of those oh
yeah
[ __ ] yeah we didn't know though we we
weren't good with it
that's crazy but i'll tell you what
it is better when it's when it's cold
when you're doing the when you're doing
the spoon it's like
it's like a little dessert yeah this was
also the first time did you growing up
did you have a dishwasher
you're about to start interrogating
yourself with that light
why are you so fat i don't know why am i
getting pretty hot on these lights hey
foley um
no i want to know why your lighting
looks so much better than that you look
like you're on [ __ ] good morning
america
i don't think i'm the big dude you
seriously look like you're at all
you look like you're
you look like you're like you're one of
those [ __ ] youtube videos where our
ghost shows up in the back
number 10 a guy is recording a podcast
when all of a sudden his bedroom door
slightly opens
yeah i think you want i think it's your
camera i
look like i'm on a good morning
you do you do i'm waiting for [ __ ]
mike strahan to [ __ ] start
start listening all over you that's what
i'm live with regis and kippy
i gotta go to kippy's now um no i think
my camera's better i got a i got a new
newer computer i gotta
it's like a whole thing i don't know
what it is man i i i look like i'm
in the you look like you're [ __ ]
house
i think i'm in the russian space station
start floating upside down like this man
i don't like this
it's just eating astronaut ice cream um
you little bubble of water you look like
you're on vhs
yeah i don't like it man i just i got a
good light i
there's a desk light at the at the at
the hotel so i got a i got a desk light
right above my thing like a like the
ring it's like two look at that
but i put an i put a tissue on it to
soften it
and i think my camera's just better i
think
yeah whatever it's a newer computer i'm
not i'm not [ __ ] bragging i'm just
[ __ ] saying
um did you know where the ghost is gonna
come
right there also i can see four doors
and they're all open what's going on in
your apartment close the [ __ ] door
you got both closets are open i see
through one door into another door
i can i can see the toilet from here
what's going on no you can't
that's not the toilet uh that's a mirror
out there i'm in the office what do you
mean that's my that's my closet
um and that's the door to the office i
can't close it because the baby's got to
come in and do a little stinker do so
she's gonna take a little dinker
the little kitty cat guys gotta come in
and do poopies
gotcha um back to where we were were you
uh you had a dishwasher growing up right
yeah what the [ __ ] that's how this
started
what am i [ __ ] ray charles's mom yeah
i had a [ __ ] dishwasher
she was washing the clothes outside and
washing the dishes outside
no i don't remember that no we had a
would you go to go to school with them
that's the only kid that would sit with
him you know what i mean
help him off the bus um
of course we had a dishwasher that we
overused
there was never any i didn't find out
until my sister-in-law told me this
that the sink is for washing the
dishwasher is for us uh sanitizing
that's how she does it she washes the
dishes
yeah we do too we're a wash we're a wash
family and it's pretty contentious
because my
wife will just throw my wife would throw
anything in the dishwasher and i'm like
you gotta wash it first
really i don't like wash i'll get
whatever it's like ocd too a little it's
just the way my mom did it it's the way
you know it was like
the every place rinsed and like i'll get
the sponge and give it like a once or
twice i'll get like the
you know if there's like sriracha sauce
or something dried on there i get that
off or whatever it is
no we we ruined a lot of uh a lot of uh
i think
yeah we went through a good amount of
dishwashers when i was in high school we
tried everything
you were in high school so you went
through multiple in four years you went
through multiple dishwashers in four
years no way i remember we had like two
or three dishwashers when i was a kid
honestly because we would [ __ ] just
throw anything in there that would
always back up or break or this or that
there'd be like [ __ ] pork chop bone
you make a [ __ ] stew out of what
you'd find
i asked little cascade stew
i'll tell you what though there was
nothing there was nothing better
than getting a fresh glass out of the
[ __ ] dishwasher still a little warm
that's the definition of clean living
right there smells a little
soapy good night yeah
[ __ ] drop some fresh cubes in that
crack open a screamer good bye and good
luck
i'll be on my way i uh
i ask because i never i my one buddy i
guess didn't have one
and we wanted we were uh i was we wanted
spoons for something
it could have been you know peanut
butter so i don't know what it was for
but i remember
he just pulled like a spoon out of the
sink and like
washed it with his hand and was like
here
and i had never known that like
there was another way i i never knew
that you just washed i was like a
seven-year-old kid or whatever i didn't
know you could wash without
a dishwasher you know i mean in
hindsight 20 20 i've lived without
dishwashers i get it but like
i remember him handing me like a wet
spoon to like do
something and i was like buddy listen
get the dishes we'll go over to denise's
house and i'll [ __ ] show you how you
do it with the cascade
i ain't using no wet [ __ ] utensil to
eat anything okay
and i don't trust you just rubbing your
finger over it either
some of my buddies uh i need this thing
steam cleaned or something
send it to the dry cleaners some of my
buddies family's
um etiquette on the sink
shocked me shocked me
like yeah just [ __ ] they ever look at
somebody's sink and there's like dishes
in there
it just looks so much grosser than it
actually is because you don't know
yeah you don't know whose dishes they
are or what mouth they've been in or
what's what was cooking
yesterday or something yeah i don't [ __ ]
with it yeah what
what spoon i'm gone um
yeah all right um coming up this is from
ian have you ever slept on your bed
without
sheets on the rag
dude really yeah still all right
um if i'm supposed to if if the sheets
all get taken down to the
laundry mat and and i don't pick them up
yeah it'll be a night or two well
that'll happen
i'll take serious i'll take serious heat
for it you and your girl are sleeping on
a
just a [ __ ] raw mattress
it's happened yeah but we have the
featherbed like you did like you just
pulled a bank job or something who's
doing like your tony soprano at the end
[ __ ] hanging out with an ar-15 on an
unmade bed
going to the mattresses um
yeah that's i've done it like in college
or drunk or something if you come home
i'll throw like i'll try
it's just too uncomfortable i'd have to
throw like a beach towel down or
i'd have to do something here's my thing
anything that's like a little bit of a
change
i'm okay with it like i can sleep in my
jeans
i can sleep with just the comforter on
the bed with the pillowcase
i don't even really need pillowcases
with the right pillow
i don't really need a pillow case i'm
not gonna lie to you
i certainly don't want a [ __ ] duvet
set with all that [ __ ]
i hate those pillows the pillows that
are on the outside we have now pillows
that are on the outside
what do you mean pillows are on the
outside the pillows that go on the
outside that have the same matching
cover as the
as the blanket the bottom of the bed and
all the duvet set
i don't like that [ __ ] we got it duvet
is new to me i never knew what to do
i'm hugging a ballerina i don't i don't
i don't i don't want all that
really stuff you want you want
functional yeah i want functional
i need a lot of pillows too kippy have i
told you about my we've gone into the
pillows a lot
i think i'm a three and then i got like
a husband i sleep with i call it
um all right let's see
another dirty dish is this is from
travis have you ever used febreze on a
sink full of dirty dishes
what the [ __ ] is that get out of here
yeah you guys are [ __ ] savages what
are we doing
i mean i'm the [ __ ] as big a dirtbag
as it gets a sink
oh i mean like maybe just spray it to
spray it down no like if
your sink smells and you don't feel like
doing all the dishes or you got people
coming over you give it a couple of
spritz to kill the smell
god damn man [ __ ] no i definitely like
in collie college sinks are different
especially when you're living with like
four or five dudes or whatever you'd be
having people over and you're like
i'm not doing all the [ __ ] andrews
dishes you know what i mean like [ __ ]
this guy but you're having people over
so i'd put like
a towel or something over the sink and
just be like hey this is awful like
we're partying don't look at the [ __ ]
sink you know what i mean
yeah when you're when when you were in
college and [ __ ] it was different it was
[ __ ] mayhem
i told you we were at the theater we
used to if
one of our chores was to do the dishes
we would just take a whole thing full of
dishes out of
out of the sink or out of our room and
just take them and throw them in a
dumpster or something like that
yeah i've done that for sure like
especially moving out of somewhere i've
been like
[ __ ] like i still try
i just moved in september i still trash
everything like i'm like dude i'll
[ __ ]
i'm not carrying this thing that was in
six bucks i'll buy a new one
this uh this place is i'm hemmed up now
like if i had to move i would there
would be you know i got a couple of days
and all that stuff
but literally up until moving into to
this apartment or the
into this building i i dude it was
literally it was like in heat i could
have been out the door
in 30 [ __ ] seconds yeah [ __ ]
computer guitar
bag of clothes i'm [ __ ] gone
different name
different city like a ghost
also that you know the guitar reminds me
i think we talked about it on the
patreon episode the song that you sang
what was it hey girl or hey beautiful or
i don't know what what what what is this
what was it
what is this interrogation what was it
that's for the patreon that's for family
whatever it was somebody said we when we
get to like
well the next benchmark for patreon
should be uh
we make a music video for that song and
i [ __ ] want to
i don't think we i don't have that song
recorded but i got plenty of tracks that
we can make
no you like you just want to use me to
spark your [ __ ] music career
hey i got a couple
you call up your mom hey kippy said he
pressed the demo
get the get the band back together
kippy's doing pay to play on k rock for
the big guy
absolutely the song was called sunny day
whatever okay i'm just saying so that
you've saying the guitar remind me um
this one's from terry t-bone
aka t-bone steak we got a t we got a
t-bone in the patreon shout out
i like it also t-bone in here shout out
big [ __ ] shout out to t-bone
if anybody i mean if anybody
if they're trying to get an episode out
on my own if anybody deserves a raise
it's [ __ ] t-bone
mcmuffin he's worth every penny that guy
does a [ __ ] bang-up job great at what
he does super funny guy from chicago
check him out
uh we'll be back there next week auntie
can't wait terry t-bone have you ever
run out of soap and just
washed yourself with shampoo and i'm
gonna come out and say for like
most of the time i do that i've used
shampoo for
probably 50 of the times i'll just use
shampoo
i like the way it smells i don't you
know what i mean i like the way it feels
too as long as it doesn't have any con
listen as long as it doesn't have any
conditioner in it
there is no difference between [ __ ]
body wash and shampoo
no there's no difference they're lying
to you
it's all marketing you're falling for it
if i would end up
you know high school college i end up in
my girlfriend's shower like her parents
maybe their short house or something
like that
and i look over and see a brand new
bottle of herbal essence
that stuff in the thousands was i used
to [ __ ]
everywhere a whole handful of that and
tug my little root too
oh yeah come out of there smelling like
liz claiborne ready for dinner good
night hello gentlemen
yeah yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] fantastic
that was
big um this is from katie
uh who has home run questions by the way
have you ever gone to the bank to try to
dispute an overdraft fee and i mean what
do we talk like
i've done that within five months ago
i've done that i've
you know i like to uh i like to fly a
little too close to the sun sometimes
and the account gets overdrawn
but i know i've learned i've learned my
lessons really i still oh
i'm like red i'm a reformed man i'll
tell you that
no trouble out of me sir they've got me
too many times on that
yeah i've gotten hit a bunch um i still
do when i call
and they go oh we can't do it i go let
me talk to your manager and he goes oh
we've already approved two within the
past six months i say zip it
i know it's three i know what are we
doing here we're going around and around
i know i'm like
you're selling the wrong you're such a
scumbag what do you mean
sorry we've already approved seven for
the week listen
listen yeah well it's also like i bought
a pack of gum you're gonna
you're gonna charge me 38 bucks for the
pack of gum get out of here bozo does it
always work
um they'll do like three every six i
forget the time because it's been a
while but there was a time like when we
were like really
struggling in comedy like we just
[ __ ] still struggle like really
struggling
and i mean you know those [ __ ] salad
days or whatever they call it like
you're just
[ __ ] i'd have no money and i'd be
like you know a hundred bucks
like oh well it's coming tomorrow then
something would hit and you've you know
you're
you're holding you're spinning all the
plates and they all drop running and
gunning
i was on the phone yeah for forever and
they make you sweat it out you're gonna
have to hold i got to talk to this guy
i'm just going buddy i don't care if you
got i don't care who you got to call
call
mr [ __ ] touchdown bank i'm sitting
here i need the [ __ ] 70 clams let's
go
get the president on the phone i don't
give a [ __ ] what you need to do
yeah yeah yeah buff up the cash i stay
away from all that stuff
religiously and thank god not knock on
formica
i haven't i haven't had any overdraft
fees in a while
well aren't you special yeah i'm sorry
we don't all have money like you okay no
i just make sure
sure i know i'm breaking balls buddy i
get you you're you've become more
responsible
i also monitor what what's in the
checking and what's in the savings and
what comes out you know what i mean
savings you got savings money i'm all
right how much am i paying you
it's an account that i've had since i
was a kid there's like five about five
bucks in it yeah
shouldn't let it go to your head either
um
all right let's see what do we got here
um this is from claire i'm a new
subscriber first question do you own up
yay hey welcome claire welcome claire do
you want a punching bag
and where is it located in your home i
just walked past an apartment that has a
bag suspended from their ceiling in
their living room
not sure if this is a sign i'm in a bad
[ __ ] area you know it ain't a good
area
i can tell you that much i'm not doing
that on park avenue i know that
um this is how trashy we were i had a
heavy
i had a heavy bag as a kid growing up
and it just never got hung up
if there's if that's the if that is the
[ __ ]
lifelong tale of the ryans
it's we have [ __ ] that's not finished or
done correctly
for sure 100 that's why you never played
varsity sports
tell you that right now never even hung
the bag huh
i could see your dad yelling at you i
got you that [ __ ] bag you never even
hung it
for whatever man i mean how am i
supposed to hang abby back by myself i'm
seven
cut me something on get a couple of guys
from home depot in here or something
like that will you pop
i know i'm like you own a construction
company call up the [ __ ]
the laborers to come over and hang this
[ __ ] thing you
tell me this is this more trashy or is
this
is this more of a clean living situation
we had a punching bag
that was your mom
keep that yep um
uh she actually lit me up a couple of
times when i was a kid she was a
scrapper
yeah i'll tell you that yeah there's
always worse on your mind irish
high fivers coal mining yak from upstate
pennsylvania
slapped a taste out of your mouth you
love that baldwin line he's going to
come for money pretty soon you say that
one more time yeah you've
been you've been pushing it too a couple
of times don't forget i don't get it
yeah it's a great term um yeah she was a
scrapper back in the day there was
always something a little more
demoralizing when your mom would smack
you around a little bit than your dad
your dad you kind of you know
like you feel like you were in an sc
hinton book or something like that
like you're one of the outsiders when
your mom did it it was real real
emasculating
tough yeah but we can do she was the
king
did you have a heavy bag we did have a
heavy bag
we did um what i was going to ask you is
we took
a old sea bag an old navy like duffel
bag
like the green one or whatever the blue
one or something built that with like
sand or
pillow cases or whatever it was and then
we bolted that and then hung that
up that's what we worked that on that's
trashy
that's probably like four times but when
people came over they were like damn
these guys are tough
you gotta hanging out front to flex on
everybody
why is this in the kitchen yeah yeah
keep it up keep asking questions
tough guy you don't want to know
yeah good times here i love it um
shout out a good good round of questions
so far uh great round
shout out to this is from andrew do you
do you or have you ever kept snacks
under your bed
god damn what is this [ __ ] no that's
sad
i know i think college when you were
like you had to keep your own st you
know college i had [ __ ]
i was i was sleeping on a [ __ ] crate
of uh cup of noodles
i mean that's different college is
different
you can't be doing i would you have
snacks under your bed now i could maybe
if you're in like a tight roommate
situation where you don't know them that
well but
yeah yeah yeah i know but still i don't
know
um this is from chad bell home run of a
question
have you ever ever ride on a parade
float and yes i have
really yeah we were we were big i think
we've talked about this on something at
some point we were big
thanksgiving day parade people um
you weren't in the philly one were you
yeah all the time yeah yeah yeah
really yeah i mean i mean i was working
with a celebrity over here
it's like actually gardner um i
actually that's exactly what my dad
looks like by the way um
it looks exactly like jim gardner um
i my aunt worked for the city
so she got the kids on and it became a
tradition we do it every year i was too
young
for a while like while my brother and
sister were going but then i got to go
um and yeah i mean i dude i literally
thought i was a celebrity i was like
[ __ ] waving to people running up
slapping hands you're on the float
you're off the float type thing
yeah i mean as a little kid [ __ ]
who's starving for attention whose
parents won't look at him
yeah i'm on the news ma what float were
you bozos on
it changed every year the one year they
were on with kelly ripa
and some no no why wh
what float were you on like the abc
float the
they're different floats my dad just
just drove behind in the jeep
he was smoking more breads out the
window i was waving through the sunroof
kevin get out and grab some candy um
yeah what float were you on no they just
they need extras for the floats like
i think for a few years we did like the
we were like
man how sad is that you're an extra on a
[ __ ] thanksgiving day parade float
man jump over that with your therapist
for a little while i don't thought you
were
thought you were [ __ ] you thought you
were a [ __ ] disney kid back in the
day now you realize you were just some
bum
waiting in line it was like they would
do charles dickens themes
so they needed like you know the one
year i remember all like top hats with
the big coats on you know we look like
you know we were from pakistani
pennsylvania or whatever we look like
[ __ ] [ __ ] now that
now that i think about it you couldn't
afford the costume you just got regular
[ __ ] on
i'm wearing my starter jacket smoking a
cig
starter jacket and a pair of freaky
freezers
i got my la lights on um
yeah it was it was uh we were big parade
people man
big parade people not proud of it but
that was you know
i'm owning it um
yeah trashy jesus christ man that really
takes me back
dad that's real garbage man that's real
[ __ ] trash
oh dude holy [ __ ] this is from javon
marshall
um i'm brand new to the patreon so
excuse me if this has been asked have
you ever had to open your door in a
drive-through because the window didn't
roll down
holy hell that's trash
that is a [ __ ] home run of a [ __ ]
question
god damn i feel like my window's
starting to go now
like it squeaks every time it goes up
and down
um jesus christ hold on sorry i gotta go
back
yeah i've never had that i remember one
time we were going up to the mountains
we were going skiing and my dad's window
stopped and we had to tape like a trash
bag up the whole time he was driving oh
yeah 12 kids and like
three parents because i was in the back
of the jeep this is the 90s dude i was
in the back
like the far back of the jeep no seat
just
[ __ ] like three ten year three seven
year olds in the back of a [ __ ]
shoe imagine if something happened you'd
be getting tossed around like a [ __ ]
bag of butter
dude none of it dude meanwhile he's got
a trash bag he's got no visibility out
the driver's side window
and he's still trying to smoke bernie's
i remember i remember
the one dad was like damn can you not
smoke and he's just like [ __ ]
yeah we're almost there he's just
[ __ ] going dude
yeah um let's see do a couple more here
and then we got to uh we got a wrap yeah
let's do it
hit me man all right just from ryan have
you ever gone streaking or skinny
dipping
i tried to go skinny dipping with uh
a girl in high school once down the
shore she was always
she was uh she was way hotter than me
all right and we just happen to be
somewhere down the shore together with
another guy
and another girl and i remember we were
the only two that would do it and she
ran like really
she made it clear that she didn't want
to be naked in the water with me
she like ran to the bay we were like on
the beach you know what i mean
like she went like far out and like dove
and it was at night too
wait you're doing night time that's like
scary movie [ __ ] dude i was i was trying
what do you mean i was a [ __ ] little
horny high school kid i'm trying to make
a move here
i [ __ ] would have done anything i
would have stormed the beaches of
normandy what are you talking about
[ __ ] dove in ocean ocean city new
jersey diving in the water at like
10 o'clock at night yikes
with my little willy sticking out that's
nuts i
dude the bait and tackle [ __ ] right
there somebody laughs
it's a little earthworm floating we got
a little meal got a little meal worm
yeah dude that's not sweet i never i
never did i don't think i was ever
really in the opportunity
to like skinny i don't know that just
seemed like that wasn't one of the
things that kids did in movies
like there was no stories of that either
like did you hear they went skinny
dipping late like that never [ __ ]
i don't that wasn't happening in my
school i don't know what was going on
you were running an underground casino
at the time yeah we were
yeah i was i was responsible businessman
here i was an entrepreneur at a young
age
once i saw a boiler room i was like boys
were open for business
that's literally what it was it was
boiler room and we opened up a casino
oh shout out to the four horsemen casino
all right last one this is a
[ __ ] great i'm so glad i [ __ ]
found this one because i wanted to use
it last time
this is from joseph um joseph
joseph good knock around name joseph
joseph vincent
yeah that's a [ __ ] great name right
isn't that great that's a [ __ ] that's
like a wise guy name
don't make me go talk to joseph vincent
um
do you tip the mailman
what excuse me i wonder why this guy's a
[ __ ] prick to us you're supposed to
tip the mailman i don't know maybe he's
got to be a mailman
what oh yeah when i was a kid i think my
our met we had like a we had one
here [ __ ] eight different guys show
up every day
you know what i mean they're changing
their house they're all uber eats guys
for you
uh but we had a steady guy all growing
up i think my parents broke him off
something at christmas or he got some uh
something he at least got some
scratchers or some mcdonald's gift cards
which i speak of often yeah i don't
think
we had norm norm for the longest time
was ours
um and i'm sure he got his beak wet we
were big with the cash back in the day
real big with the cash
so i'm sure he got his norm i mean norm
was of i remember what his last day when
everybody met in the cul-de-sac and said
bye to norm
really um yeah i was i mean dude he was
you know he [ __ ] held the block down
for like a [ __ ]
for like a dubski you know what i mean
[ __ ] we had to give him his farewell
he did 35 and out dude you know
damn yeah um that's it that's a wrap
guys [ __ ] fantastic round of
questions we appreciate it
hopefully we are back in the [ __ ]
studio we're back at toady's next week
um we got a lot of there was a lot of
[ __ ] [ __ ] flying at us this week we
made it [ __ ] works
um you know we appreciate it thanks for
listening as always please make sure you
rate if you subscribe on itunes
full video available on youtube that
patreon.com is [ __ ] cooking guys
getting this is the next bitcoin baby
get in [ __ ] low
tell you you're an og you know i mean i
just want to reiterate what kevin said i
just want to say thank you for everyone
for bearing with us this week
rocking on the zoom like you said we'll
be back at toady's next week hopefully
all things go well
uh should have some some great things
coming up we love it
a lot of good guests in store it'll be a
[ __ ] hot
hot comeback baby we appreciate your
love we appreciate your questions we
appreciate your support
and we'll see you next time peace peace
but wait a minute kippy before we let
the folks get out of here
what's happening real quick talk one
more time about our good friends over
there
on the old stereo app doesn't matter
whether you got an iphone or an android
you can sign up for stereo app for
free yeah love that stereo app baby it's
like a you know it's like a little bonus
ayg you get you sign
up use use uh use one of our links the
link will be in the description of this
it's
uh stereo dot com slash kevin ryan or
stereo.com
foley we get to wet our beaks a little
bit you can ask us questions live on the
air you
you know you record it sends we play it
live we answer it live
it's a lot of fun it's a good way for
you guys to interact with us check it
out
get involved baby check it out and get
involved gang we love you we'll see you
next time
peace